when mathematicians encounter a problem
right often for many many years decades
sometimes centuries they but their head
against the problem trying to resolve
the problem in one way or another and
sometimes problems could be very very
obstinate in fact you guys should all
become these it doesn't matter if you
can understand them or not you should
just read them and just reckon with the
fact that there are maths problems that
if you solve them you get a million
dollars so some of these problems are
centuries old and they've defied you no
mathematical solution okay now once you
stumble upon a solution to something you
like Wow I gave us new insight again
it's new technique it's a bit like
discovering like I'm a new tool like
inventing bahama although lever or
something like that you're like these
things awesome what else can I do with
this right you started just not looking
for nails everywhere okay quadratics
are a bit like that okay what's madness
I'm not have to solve it they unlocked a
whole host of other kinds of problems
okay and that's what today's lesson is
about so here's a simple quadratic and
we can solve this it's directly easy to
factorize what's the factorization
plus five take away three okay excellent
out of which we get out to solutions or
zeros or roots in this case they are
negative Paul at five it's been a long
day maybe five four three so far so good
but then you have a look down here what
this unlocks is a whole bunch of other
solutions just look carefully down the
page before you do anything with these
right all of these problems are really
this problem but in disguise right all
of these problems are this problem but
just kind of very different clothes so
for example this is anything let's have
a look at B now I'm going to show you
two ways to do this there are really
different methods they're just different
ways of putting the notation down okay
here's the way to pressure to do X to
the 4 plus 2x squared minus so this is
not a quadratic this is a quartic isn't
it but it's a particular kind of quick
it's not just anyone I can solve it the
same way that I just solved the first
one suggestions yeah okay so I can
introduce the substitution now I can
choose any letter I like but just for
the sake of consistency and so you
familiar with the convention the normal
letter that people use is you okay so
I'm going to say let u equal x squared
so if that's the case I guess a little
bit like if you just know it's a kind of
you it's I suppose B that we are not
just writing features to solve things
for ourselves we were trying to
communicate with them with others I mean
that's why convention is useful could
convention is just another word for
language right and so we all have an
agreed-upon language which is
precisely because we all agree min
otherwise because the so I'm going to
use lowercase D Droste
shouldn't be that surprised because out
language is very different like well
this your 60 seconds ago I'm gonna bond
is that okay this substitution in one
step
it simply took this problem it literally
turns this problem into this problem
right because I got new squared plus two
equals which is identical to what I had
before right
except I've got user said exit so I
could say this U is 503 now pause
because what I've done is introduce a
substitution right what I have solved is
not the question I always given right
I've solved that other question of my
own invention
so being I've gone away from their
question I've got to return back this U
is an introduction that I have made so
I'm going to go back to what they've
given me which is x squared okay so at
this point you're like oh hold on a
second now I have a problem well not so
much a problem I just have to know that
for real values of X there's no
solutions to this right there's no
solutions to this part of the equation
there are only solutions to this part
right the way that I'll ride my formal
is I'd say because this is or I have to
I've got two solutions branching on x
squared
we're three over there for that pot it's
important that I actually say that I
explained why that thing just disappears
I'm not just thinking or again I just
say oh I just don't gonna pay attention
that pot I had to pay attention to it
I'm resolving it in this particular way
by the way don't say there's no solution
because there are solutions they're just
not real and we'll get into that okay
this of course this is just our normal
just take the square root so I have two
solutions these guys okay yeah
it is the very tiny note not as
important as the actual process we just
went through but you see these two lines
they kind of contradict each other right
it's because they come from two
different places so really it would be
best if I sort of tie this all up in a
deep bow all right so I should say
therefore x equals only right that just
shows that I've taken both into account
I'm not saying both of these at the same
time because they're directly
contradictory right I'm taking both of
those to say all right in summary this
okay the starting suggestion you gave me
was the introduced to substitution you
don't need to do that let's take this
line again okay take it as our new
starting point okay now I read this
first question is that's a quadratic in
X just like if I say okay I've got f of
X equals blah blah blah this would be a
function in X X is the variable okay
this is also a function in X but I can
rewrite it as a function in x squared
that's what this implies or this
substitution we just introduced right so
here's how I'm going to rewrite it it's
just once that this X to the four right
is really x squared squared plus 2x
squared minus
so no substitutions required I mean the
substitution is kind of there in the
back of my mind right but now what I
have is not a quadratic in X it's a
quadratic in x squared you see that and
you can have the quadratic in anything
you like as you can see on page so now
from here I'm gonna go straight to this
light here my factorization right it's
gonna be x squared plus five x squared
minus three just like a normal quadratic
now that left hand side x squared plus
five there's no factorization you can do
with real numbers anyway okay so x
squared plus five he just Facebook okay
but this guy I can write him as the
difference of squares doesn't matter
that 3 is not a perfect square I know
what should be this week so I've got X
minus root three X plus three reasons so
what we call this is this is the
factorization over the real numbers
because everything I can factorize with
a real number like say the square root
of three I have right and all the stuff
that can't factorize any further I just
leave it okay that's as far factorize
that is gone now from this I could say
all right this is never gonna be equal
to zero
just think about it visually right this
is a parabola and it's being raised five
units it's never gonna be equal to zero
its we have language piece that way so
this is positive definite okay so I
don't need to worry about it these two
guys are where I get these solutions
from so x equals plus or minus root
three and I've heard so just personally
in terms of the setting yeah I kind of
prefer this one it has a bit of an edge
in terms of it didn't a little bit
quicker it's also a skill that you're
going to need to learn and expand on in
the coming terms okay so I kind of so I
think that I kind of prefer this but
these are both fine which is why I'm
happy to show you both